whenever they talk about diversity it
just cracks me up that they miss the
whole point of diversity they want
diversity but they want everybody to be
the same in their diversity if they
wanted to invite somebody to talk about
diversity and uh lgbtq environment I
would be the most diverse person that
they would ever meet because I'm
transgender I have gendered Identity
Disorder so I'm still in your group
you're not going to find a more diverse
character but they kick me out they
don't want diversity they want diversity
as long as it lines up with their agenda
that's what they're teaching
universities every time I go to Deni if
you're white male and especially like
Christian and middle class or anything
else you're not allowed you're excluded
how is that diversity